try to evaluate the following integral
so I'm assuming you've had a go at it so
let's let's work through this together
and if at any point you get inspired
always feel free to pause the video and
continue on with it on your own so the
first thing that might have jumped out
at you we have a rational expression the
degree in the numerator is the same as
the degree in the denominator so maybe a
little bit of algebraic long division is
called for so let's do that let's take x
squared minus 1 let's take x squared
minus 1 and divide it into x squared
within a different color
divide it into x squared plus X minus 5
so x squared plus X minus 5 and so let's
look at the highest degree term so how
many times as x squared go into x
squared well it goes one time let me
write this in a new color goes one time
one times x squared minus one is just
going to be x squared minus one and I
subtract this green expression from this
move expression or I could just add the
negative on it so let me just take the
negative of it so it's going to be
negative x squared plus one and we're
going to get the X Squared's x squared
minus x squared is zero so those cancel
out and we're going to be left with X
we're going to be left with X and the
negative five plus one is negative four
so we have X minus four left over so we
can rewrite the expression that we're
trying to find the antiderivative of we
can rewrite it as one one plus X minus
four one plus X minus four over over x
squared minus one over x squared maybe
we'll do that in that purple color since
I already used it as the purple over x
squared minus one so we did one thing we
now we have a lower degree in the
numerator than we have in the
denominator and obviously this is fairly
straightforward to take the
antiderivative of but what do we do now
it's not clear if we look at x squared
minus one its derivative would be two X
which is the same degree as this but
it's not X minus four so doesn't look
like you substitution is going to is
going to help us with
this so what can we do now and now we
can take out another tool in our
algebraic toolkit is we can sense you do
or we will do partial fraction expansion
which is essentially writing this as the
sum of two rational expressions that
have a lower degree in the denominator
so what do I mean by that so this term
right over here X minus four over x
squared minus one we can rewrite that as
X minus four over instead of x squared
minus one we can factor this this is X
plus one times X minus one so let's
write that this is X plus one times X
minus one and when we think about
partial fraction expansion we say okay
well can we write this as the sum of as
the sum of something let's call that a
over over X plus one over X plus one
plus something else let's call that B
plus B over X minus one can we do that
and to attempt to do that let's if we
had to just add these two things what
would we get well we would find a common
denominator which would be X plus one
times X minus one and so you would have
and if any of this looks from unfamiliar
I encourage you to review the Witte
videos on partial fraction expansion
because that's exactly what we're doing
right over here but this would be equal
to if you were to add the two your
common denominator would be the product
so it'd be X plus one it would be X plus
1 times X minus 1 X minus 1 and then so
the first term I would multiply the
numerator and the denominator times X
minus 1 so it'd be a times X minus 1 a
times X minus 1 plus B the second term
are multiplied the numerator denominator
times X plus 1 times X plus 1 and so
what do we get we this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to ax
maybe I'll do this all in one color this
is going to be equal to a whoops
a X minus a plus B X plus B plus B X
plus B and then all of that over the
stuff that we keep writing over and over
again actually let me just copy and
paste this so copy and paste I could use
that over and over again so we have that
over that let's see so now we can group
the X terms and so we can rewrite this
as so if we take ax plus BX that's going
to be a plus B times X and then we have
and then we have a negative a and a B so
plus B minus a and I'll just put
parentheses around that just so I kind
of group these these constant terms and
then all of that's going to be divided
by good thing I copied and pasted that X
plus 1 times X minus 1 and so now this
is the this is the crux of partial
fraction expansion we say okay we kind
of went through this whole exercise on
the thesis that we could do this that
there is some a and B for which this is
true and so if there is some a and B for
which this is true then a plus B must be
the coefficient on the X term right over
here so a plus B must be equal to 1 must
be equal to this coefficient and B minus
a must be equal to the constant must be
equal to negative 4 or if they are then
we will found an A and a B so let's do
that so I'll do it up here since I have
a little bit of real estate so a plus B
is going to be equal to 1 and B minus a
or I could write that as negative a plus
B is equal to negative 4 is equal to
negative 4 C we could add the left-hand
sides and add the right-hand sides and
then we would the A's would disappear we
would get 2 B is equal to negative 3 or
B is equal to negative 3 halves and then
a is we know that a
is equal to a is equal to one minus B
which would be equal to one plus
three-halves since b is negative
three-halves which is equal to five
halves
a is equal to 5 halves b is equal to
negative three halves and just like that
we can rewrite this whole integral in a
way that is a little bit easier to take
the antiderivative 1/1 plus a over X
plus one a is 5 halves and so I could
just write that is let me write it this
way five halves times one over X plus
one and I wrote it that way because it's
very straightforward to take the
antiderivative of this and then plus B
over X minus one which is going to be
negative three halves so I'll just write
it as minus three halves minus three
halves times one over X minus one that
was this right over here DX DX notice
all I did is I took this I took this
expression right over here and I did a
little bit of partial partial fraction
expansion into these into these two I
guess you could say expressions or terms
right over there and now it's fairly
straightforward to integrate this
antiderivative of 1 is just going to be
X antiderivative of five halves 1 over X
plus one it's going to be plus five
halves the natural log of the absolute
value of x plus one we were able to do
that because the derivative of x plus 1
is just 1 so the derivative is there so
that we can take the antiderivative with
respect to X plus 1 you could also do u
substitution like we've done in previous
examples U is equal to X plus one and
over here this is going to be minus
three-halves times the natural log of
the absolute value of x minus 1 by the
same exact logic where how we would take
the antiderivative there and of course
we cannot forget our constant and there
we have it we've been able to integrate
we were able to evaluate
you ate this expression